the new August update for xbox one comes  with a range of new features for upload  you now have the ability to both like  and share your clips from the hub you  can select a clip and hit Y to like it  or you can bring up the transport  controls during playback to both like  and share the clip once you select share  you have the option to share it to both  your activity feed for all your friends  and followers to see or to a message  which means you can now send official  upload your clips directly we've also  added a trending section to the upload  hub see the most popular clips as chosen  by you the community be sure to add the  official habla gamertag as a friend and  start sending us your clips